the most difficult thing a web developer  ever has to do is center a div both  horizontally and vertically with css  there are hundreds of ways to get the  job done but the classic approach is to  use absolute positioning then move it  down and to the right by 50  by using the top and left properties  then move it back the other direction by  translating it 50  this confusing hack was the gold  standard until flexbox came around where  we can make the parent div  a flexible column or row then align and  justify the children  in the center that's a great option but  today we can do it with even fewer lines  of code using grid layout just to find  the parent div as a grid and then tell  it to place the items in the center  yes it's just that simple